hallo Leute hier sieht eure Wahl
meine hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
Meinung und willkommen zu einem neuen
Adventskalender auspack Video und heute
werde ich zum Imker nein heute gibt's
ein Honig Adventskalender ja es gibt
einfach von allen mittlerweile ein
Adventskalender wir müssen damit
klarkommen deswegen probieren wir Sie
auch alle aus
[Musik]
meine Begrüßung war ein bisschen schnell
das tut mir leid in viele Leute
schreiben mir dass sie sich so schön
entspannen können zu meiner
Adventskalender Videos und das möchte
ich natürlich auch unterstützen aber um
ehrlich zu sein mache ich diese
Begrüßung seit 8 Jahren hallo Leute hier
ist wieder eure malwanne ich will die
auch hinter mich bringen also heute
haben wir ein Honig Adventskalender das
ist wirklich was ganz besonderes bin
aber nicht selber drauf gekommen hier
einmal Danke schön an die Person die es
mir vorgeschlagen hat ich bin gespannt
ich bin mir nicht sicher ist Honig ein
kontroverses Nahrungsmittel mittlerweile
eigentlich schon ne weil die Bienen die
sollten wir auch mal in Ruhe lassen denn
ohne Bienen haben wir nichts habt ihr
mal dieses Bild von einem Supermarkt
gesehen dass wir aussehen würde wenn es
keine Bienen mehr geben würde
und toll toll super toll der sieht ja
schön aus Honig Adventskalender von
gregas Imkerei was man ein paar
heartfacts ne aus Engelskirchen der
Adventskalender kostet
49,95 €. also wenn mir denn jetzt mit
Supermarkt Honig vergleichen wir haben
hier anscheinend einen Kilopreis von
79,30 € und im Supermarkt kostet ein
Kilo Honig 10 € 15
wir werden es mal sehen was ist denn
diese gregas Imkerei wir sind Leon und
Florian Greger unsere kleine Familien
Imkerei liegt im Bergischen Land ca 30
km östlich von Köln unsere
bienenerzeugnisse stammen ausschließlich
von uns und unseren Bienenvölkern unser
Honig stammt von Pflanzen aus unserer
Umgebung und ist damit zu 100%
naturbelassen also ein sehr regionales
Produkt wenn man aus der Ecke kommt ich
meine jetzt Berlin das ist jetzt aber es
ist immer noch regional wo kommt denn
Honig sonst her kennen vor weil deutsche
kann nicht so viel produzieren werden
rund 80% des Honigs Import Honig in
Deutschland selten ein regionales
Produkt bevor ich den Adventskalender
jetzt aufmache möchte ich euch noch
zeigen dass ich sehr gut vorbereitet bin
ich habe hier getoasteten Toast und hier
habe ich noch ganz bisschen Butter diese
butterschale habe ich von meiner
Schwiegermama zum Geburtstag bekommen
hier steht Butter bei die Fische und
dann legt man die Butter bei die Fische
und dazu gibt es noch ein Butter bei die
Fische Messer und als weitere Waffe
damit ich keinen Zuckerschock Kriege
habe ich mir hier Tee rein gemacht und
das habe ich auch zum Geburtstag
bekommen von meiner anni wow 50 €, also
ich finde 50 € ist noch so ein Preis
wenn man den für ein Adventskalender
ausgeben kann man sagen ja der hat 50 €
gekostet ich meine da sind 24 Produkte
drin 50 € finde ich es immer ein guter
Richtwert und wenn man selber einfüllen
würde und man sagt ja ja ich drehe schon
ja
okay dann tschüssikowski würde ich sagen
ne ja mach's gut
wenn man sich nämlich vorstellt dass man
einen selber basteln gibt man ja auch
schon teil teilweise ein bis zwei Euro
pro Türchen aus und dann kommt man ja
auch ganz schnell auf 50 Euro also ja
und jetzt habe ich noch nicht mal ein
Türchen aufgemacht und fang schon an
diesen Kalender zu loben dieses Video
ist nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle
dieses Videos nicht gesponsert doch der
ist gespannt hat von deutschen Bienen
ist auch toll ähm wegen morgens ein
Türchen aufmachen Frühstück ich esse
gerne Honig also manchmal habe ich
Phasen damals mir ständig aufs Brot
manchmal halt nicht so oder ist mir das
zu süß das Zeug wir beginnen mit Türchen
Nummer 6 Spaß
und hier ist nicht so ganz normaler
Honig drin hier ist
so ein Honig ohne Label ohne nix einfach
Honig ich sehe gerade hinten auf der
Verpackung kann man dann lesen was es
ist aber vielleicht machen wir das eher
so dass ich das erstmal errate also wir
haben hier ein rosa Glas ich habe mich
schon gespoilert das ist Erdbeere mit
Honig crazy Kombination sieht eher aus
wie so eine Milchcreme beschneidigen wir
mal hier so ein Scheibchen ab ne hier
haben wir unseren professionellen testos
ein bisschen Puder schmeckt dann halt
einfach besser ein bisschen hungrig ich
will den Amazon probieren oh mein Gott
das ist Toms erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit
Honig eines Tages dachte Tom an ein
leckeres Erdbeermarmeladebrot mit Honig
Leute Gregs äh gregas Imkerei verkauft
das unter Toms erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit
Honig ich glaube ihr kriegt Lizenz
Probleme macht das lieber nicht ich
liebe die Konsistenz weil die so richtig
schön fest ist fühlt sich an wie so ein
Honig Butterschmalz oh sieht das toll
aus
super toll also der Erdbeergeschmack
kommt zum Nachgang und es ist auch
lecker aber es ist jetzt nicht Erdbeere
in deine Fresse rein
finde ich sehr sehr süß wenn es so
kreativ weitergeht dann freue ich mich
natürlich zwei okay hier haben wir jetzt
ein Glas Senf auch toll dieser honig
wirkt flüssiger als der andere ja gut
ist eine sehr klebrige Angelegenheit
hier
[Musik]
ich rate den Geschmack
ich habe gerade das herzhaftes gesagt
und es ist auf den ersten Eindruck
wirklich Curry aber ich glaube ich tippe
das ist kurkuma ist Kurkuma mit Honig
kurkuma ist sehr gesund und Honig ja
auch Honig ist ja antibakteriell also
deswegen macht man auch ein Tee mit
Honig das ist sehr gesund muss den
Kurkuma Honig noch mal hier mit einem
Toast probieren die haben das sehr gut
gemeint mit dem Kurkuma bei der Erdbeere
war man sich nicht sicher hier checkt
man sofort
ich mag Kurkum eigentlich nicht so gerne
aber es ist interessant also es ist auch
was Besonderes aber man muss aber
Kurkuma mögen das gerne zu essen wir
machen eine Honig Bewertung der erste
Erdbeer Honig bekommt von mir Nummer
vier von fünf Bienchen und der bekommt
zweieinhalb von fünf Bienchen Türchen
Nummer drei ah der sieht ja cool aus ich
weiß nicht seht ihr diese rote Farbe der
ist so richtig Rubinrot ich finde schon
sehr cool sehr aufregend ist ein
richtiges Erlebnis hier diese Honig hier
ah ja das ist eindeutig wenn ich mit
meinem appeller will noch mal rein
Waldfrucht also alles was immer so
dunkelrot ist da weiß man dass es
Waldfrucht Blaubeere
Blaubeere bin ich ein guter Tester muss
meine Geschmacksnerven neutralisieren
Türchen Nummer vier ich würde auf den
ersten Blick sagen dies ist ein
handelsüblicher Honig mit nichts
Besonderem dran aber wie wir gregas
Imkerei kennen wird da jetzt eine
Geschmacksexplosion auf uns warten
riecht wie handelsüblicher Honig
nee dann irgendwas besonderes dran
ich weiß es wird aber Wumms ich habe
vergessen meinen Blaubeer Honig zu
bewerten 4,5 von 5 Bienchen und bei dem
jetzt tippe ich dass es Ingwer Honig ist
Ingwer mit Honig
der zweieinhalb bekommen von mir 3,5 von
5 Bienchen ich glaube es wird wirklich
immer nur Honig drin sein hätte gehofft
dass auch so vielleicht mal so eine
Bienenwachskerze oder so drin ist wir
sind ja noch nicht beim Ende Türchen
Nummer fünf okay das ist witzig es ist
jetzt was anderes drin blumenkerne
bienenfreundliche Sonnenblumensamen
damit ich Sonnenblumen einpflanze guck
mal ich wollte schon wieder essen
erschreckend die gelben Blumen liefern
wichtige Pollen und Nektar zu einer
Tracht Armen Zeit doch durch neue
Züchtungen versiegt diese Quelle die
riesigen Blüten sind in den letzten
Jahren als Schnittblumen in Mode
gekommen der gelbe Pollen der auf die
Tischdecke rieselt stört er gewaltig
Züchter und Handel haben darauf reagiert
und bieten als Saatgut fast nur noch
schnittfeste Sorten ohne nennenswerten
vollen an fatal für Bienen denn sie
suchen an diesen Arten verzweifelt nach
Nahrung der soll mal noch mal sagen dass
man bei meinen Videos nicht klären das
sind Samen für bienenfreundliche
Sonnenblumen die auch Pollen haben
tolles Türchen man hat was dazugelernt
man muss sich das aber selber beibringen
ich hätte gerne so ein kleines Booklet
mit dem Adventskalender gehabt gibt's
leider nicht ein kleines Büchlein zu dem
Adventskalender wäre toll dann könnte
man nämlich gleich nachlesen warum man
Sonnenblumen bekommt und wie sie zum
Beispiel den Ingwer mit dem Honig
vermischen wir sind bei Nikolaus
angekommen Tierchen Nummer 6 ist es
Nikolaus wir lieben diesen Tag ich kann
es nicht oft genug sagen da ist die
Nummer 6 überraschenderweise ist
natürlich Nummer sechs Honig drin hätte
ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet aber der
Geruch
natürlich nur aus rein professionellen
wissenschaftlichen Gründen muss ich
jetzt noch mal den Honig mit Toast
probieren
sind mit Honig so simpel und es macht
instant aus deinem toasten Franzbrötchen
sehr lecker fünf von fünf Bienchen okay
das war doch ein cooles sexistisch
Türchen natürliche Nummer 7 und wir
haben langsam schon einen Zuckerschock
blauer Honig die sind verrückt sind sehr
tiefes Blau blau in deine Fresse rein
blau
boah ey wenn ich ein Kind wäre würde ich
lieben es macht einfach meinen Toast
blau
das können jetzt sein dass sie nur
Lebensmittelfarbe reingemacht haben weil
der Honig relativ Honig mäßig schmeckt
aber wir finden es raus Spirulina Blau
im Honig das ist noch mal Spirulina ah
okay Spirulina blau
ich würde wieder sagen handelsübel an
klassischer Honig
nee das ist doch schon wieder irgendwas
faul an diesem Honig
ich würde sagen Zitrone Ananas wenn ich
jetzt Ananas lese okay dann schmecke ich
es auch aber so hätte ich es vielleicht
nicht rausgefunden vier von fünf
Bienchen und der Spirulina für den
Effekt 55 Bienchen ich vergesse nämlich
die ganze Zeit zu bewerben kommen wir
zum Türchen Nummer 9 und damit meine
Türchen
okay aber so wie wir kriegen das Imkerei
kennen haben die wieder was vorbereitet
es riecht nach Karamell
ein sommerlicher Abend nach Karamell
nein
Null von fünf Bienchen was ist oh und
das bei meinem Türchen Nummer 9
Lakritze im Honig ja ganz ehrlich ja es
schmeckt so wie man sich Lakritze mit
Honig vorstellt so schmeckt dieser
Lakritze Honig vor allem wenn man was
Süßes erwartet und dann das hier
probiert nee tut mir leid Lakritze Honig
ich brauche ein Stück Toasties
spüre welche Nummer 10 wird jetzt viel
besser ja wir haben
undefinierbare Samen bienenfreundliche
Wildblumenwiese ich finde Wildblumen
sind eh schöner als so
standardrosen tulpennecken was so alles
gibt's nee keine Blume oder nur ein
Gewürz kann man bei sich verstreuen aber
natürlich erst im nächsten Jahr ne weil
es so ein bisschen die Saison vorbei
höchster Nummer 11 das sehe ich schon
also das erkennt man doch Schokolade hä
Himberg
oh das ist ein klassischer 55
Bienenhonig die Himbeere ist so schön
sauer der Honig ist süß wir sind bei der
Hälfte schon angekommen tschüss
Karamellcreme
aber es ist bestimmt
jedem Minute wenn ich kenne den
Geschmack ich kenne ihn ich kenne ihn
ich kenne ihn oh fühle ich mich gerade
blöd ich will den Geschmack nicht lesen
weil dann weiß ich doch gleich
Sanddorn oh sanddorn ist jetzt auch
nicht was man oft ist aber wir waren mal
auf Rügen und auf Rügen ist ja alles aus
Sanddorn also da haben sie Sanddorn
Kuchen Sanddorn Marmelade Sanddorn
Schnapsen da habe ich dann Sanddorn
probiert Sanddorn Hammer Kombination 55
Bienchen viele honigkombinationen sie
einfach gemacht haben 13 meine Damen und
Herren
weißer Honig ähm wollt ihr mich
eigentlich komplett verarscht das sieht
einfach aus wie Zuckerguss nichts
besonderes aber wenn wir jetzt gleich
probieren dann werden wir sagen oh mein
Gott hätte ich niemals erwartet
nee ich komme nicht drauf
schmeckt einfach wie guter Honig ich
schmecken nichts anderes raus als Honig
ihr braucht den neutralisierungstoast
ich kann es euch nicht sagen Raps Honig
Raps Honig sieht jetzt einfach mega
fancy aus und muss dann von dieser
gelben Raps Blume sein warum ist denn
der so weiß ich verstehe das nicht hab's
Honig was die Sorte so besonders macht
Raps Honig ist eine besonders milde und
cremige Honigsorte die es häufig auch
aus der Region zu kaufen dass er auch so
beliebt ist liegt unter anderem an
seinem besonderen süßen Geschmack er ist
sehr mild deswegen kann man ihn gut zum
Backen verwenden und er hat aber nicht
so viele Antioxidantien wie andere Honig
ich hoffe ihr haltet mich jetzt nicht
für allzu dumm ich würde sagen vier von
fünf nicht zu viel über meinen
Bewerbungssystem nach es hat Glück
Nummer 14 14 sieht aus wie der Sanddorn
guck mal bis jetzt war noch nichts
doppelt drin die hätten ja auch sagen
können hier wir haben den dann machen
wir das noch einmal voll nein die denken
sich für so viele Türchen Honig aus 14
sieht aus wie wir das schon kennen
ich möchte sagen Banane aber das ist
falsch
mein Fleisch ist es Banane Hagebutte
klar ich kenne den Geschmack von
Hagebutte in und auswendig aber sehr
lecker Hagebutte in Honig funktioniert
sehr gute kommt auch vier von fünf
frische was Leute manchmal liebe ich
meinen Job die sitze hier und frühstücke
und wir gucken jetzt einfach mal was ein
Türchen Nummer 15 drin ist diese Seite
kenne ich errate ich jetzt mal das ist
Lavendel Kornblumen die ist wunderschön
die Kornblume meine Damen und Herren es
ist Zeit für Türchen Nummer 16 nicht
wiederhole Türchen Nummer 16 vom
Aussehen ähneln sich hier sehr viele ich
möchte auch noch vielleicht einen grünen
Honig okay schöne Farbe vom Aussehen
würde ich sagen Chili aber vom Geschmack
Red Hot Chili Peppers mit Honig nicht zu
verwechseln mit Naomis Katze 17
langweilig der sieht aus wie ganz
normaler Honig ist das einfach nur ganz
normaler Honig und nichts Cooles dabei
jetzt würde ich sagen Zitrone Zitrone
okay also ich merke auch den krassen
Unterschied zwischen Ananas und Honig
und Zitrone ich würde mal interessieren
wie es auf dem Brot schmeckt
krass so schmeckt der sehr sauer und
wenn man ihn dann so mit ein bisschen
Brot und Butter ist verfliegt diese
Säure aber sie wird in die mischt sich
in so ein Geschmack rein der dann so
sich erst entfalte der dann ganz toll
ist fünf von fünf Bienchen für den Honig
Nummer
18 ist wieder was Rotes
und diesmal ist das rote jetzt ist es
waldbeer jetzt ist Waldbeere
also dieser Honig ist ein bisschen
kristallisierter als der andere
Cranberry Sauerkirsche die schmecke ich
die sautische jetzt nicht so krass raus
man schmeckt halt dass es irgendwie eine
rote Frucht ist
das Gefühl ich packe diesen Kalender
schon seit drei Jahren aus 19 das ist
mit braunen Stückchen das ist bestimmt
cookies and cream das riecht wie Cookies
und cream
Vanille aber oh mein Gott ist dieser
Honig cremig Sauerkirsche der war schon
irgendwie so ein bisschen kristallisiert
und der ist wie das glatteste was man
jemals gegessen hat dieser Honig ist so
cremig wow ganz klare 55 Bienchen für
das glatteste Mundgefühl was mir ein
Honig jemals gemacht hat welche
Geschmacksrichtung haben sie noch für
uns vorbereitet Türchen Nummer Uwe wir
sind bei den 20ern einen 20 ich werde
schon ein bisschen himmelig und das
sieht mir noch ganz klar nach Schokolade
aus Schokolade hör mal das ist kein
Schokolade das ist was anderes doch ich
glaube das ist Schokolade ja es ist
Schokolade ist peinlich ich will nicht
mal sagen was es ist es ist nämlich kein
Schokolade aber ich war mir gerade kurz
sicher dass es Schokolade ist habe ich
ein bisschen nicht das soll Lavendel
sein müssen sie sich verpackt haben okay
also verwirrte drei von fünf und fünf
Bienchen oh nein ich bin so blöd sind
wir bei den 20ern angekommen und macht
sie die 21 auf so jetzt kommt der
Lavendel also mal schauen ist es
Lavendelhonig das ist Lavendel wow ich
hatte nicht gedacht dass ich so eine
tolle Nase habe und wirklich sagen kann
das ist Lavendel
schmeckt wie ein Hustenbonbon vom vom
Apotheke den Lavendelhonig würde ich
aber glaube ich nur für Tee verwenden um
einfach dann noch mal so ein Lavendel
Geschmack reinzubringen und ich mag
Lavendel abends zu trinken weil es mir
so ein Gefühl von Ruhe gibt und jetzt
ist gleich Schlafenszeit dafür kriegt
der vier von fünf der Geschmack ist aber
nicht so meins so was war denn jetzt die
21 Lavendel Honig und Schokolade dafür
von fünf Mädchen 22 wir werden jetzt
hier ein bisschen ernster ich bin
nämlich Adventskalender Kritiker und das
ist hier keine Unterhaltungssendung also
das Glas lässt sich gut öffnen
wir schauen auf den swirl ja gute
Performance hier bleibt ein kleiner
nupsi hängt genauso wollen wir es haben
dann schauen wir uns erstmal die Farbe
an tolles glänzend der Geschmack
schmeckt nach Blume keine Ahnung was sie
diesem Honig beigefügt haben schmeckt
allerdings sehr lecker ich würde jetzt
aus dem Stand sagen eine 3,5 von 5 dafür
das ist halt guter Honig ist und nichts
besonderes bei sich trägt
sommerblütenhonig es schmeckt nach Blume
[Musik]
so dann machen wir weiter mit unserem
Küchen 23 wir öffnen es leicht
lässt sich gut öffnen muss man sagen ja
können wir uns mal jetzt einen ersten
Blick von machen mein Gott sieht das
scheußlich aus ein erdiger Ton würde ich
sagen wir haben keinen swirl das ist
also ein festerer Honig es riecht so wie
es aussieht
ich würde mir das nicht aus Brot
schmieren ich glaube es ist Honig mit
Minze Pfefferminze mit Honig aber
wiederum für einen Tee also jetzt nicht
in einen Minztee bitte reinmachen aber
wenn man so ein ja irgendwie so einen
leichten Grüntee vielleicht Geschmack
hat oder so dann so ein Löffel
Pfefferminz Honig gerade Kombi ja ich
gebe dem vier von fünf tolle Idee
Geschmack okay
und jetzt bin ich wieder Vanessa wir
sind am 24 Türchen angekommen es ist
Weihnachten ihr habt so viel Honig
gegessen dass ihr absolut kein
heizkratzen Erkältung oder sonst was
bekommen habt dann Honig ist wunderbar
antibakteriell
und jetzt stelle ich Tee getrunken weil
ihr gar nicht wusstet was ihr mit diesem
Honig anfangen sollt und Tee ist
bekanntlicherweise sehr gesund und hält
einen von Erkältungen ab und jetzt gehen
wir zu unserem Adventskalender was soll
ich hier jetzt drin sein oh ein Honig
ach wirklich ich habe schon eine
Vermutung okay
war aber das irgendwie so seht ihr das
was hat sie auch so ein Schaum hier oben
und dann macht man
das so na klar das muss man gut
durchrühren nicht das obere essen ja der
muss auf jeden Fall einfach durchgerührt
werden ich kann nicht richtig bewerten
weil ich habe zu viel Gewürz probiert
aber ich kann schon sagen was es ist
glaube ich ja Glühwein Lebkuchen na gut
Glühwein Lebkuchen und so ja klar für
den 24 das lebpunkt natürlich ein toller
Geschmack auch wenn ich jetzt hier mir
wirklich die Gewürz Bombe in den Mund
geschoben habe ich mache das mal aufs
Brot ich wette das kommt mit Brot besser
auf dem Brot funktioniert das wieder
besser aber für den waffenstart den
Lebkuchen Honig und ich hatten vier von
fünf Bienchen
ich habe das Geld
also wir haben schon herausgefunden dass
der vom Preis weit über dem Supermarkt
Honig liegt aber ich würde das hier an
dieser Stelle überhaupt nicht mitzählen
denn das ist so ein richtiger Erlebnis
Adventskalender auch wenn
es euch geht finde ich das super
spannend weil man ganze Zeit neue Sachen
probiert die man einfach noch nie
probiert hat also ich habe noch nie
Honig mit einer anderen Kombination als
Honig probiert und deswegen ähm empfehle
ich diesen Kalender zu 100% tatsächlich
ich war ja schon von Anfang an sehr
positiv gestimmt ich weiß nicht warum
ich habe keinen Kontakt zu gregas
Imkerei wir haben uns noch nie gesehen
gehört irgendwas aber ich finde die Idee
einfach nur mega cool es ist nachhaltig
verpackt die Außenverpackung ist Pappe
dann haben wir hier dieses Innenlebens
Pappe wahrscheinlich kann man hier auch
noch Blumen rein züchten oder so keine
Ahnung und dann haben wir diese
wiederverwendbaren Gläser als
Aufbewahrung für den Honig ja der
Kalender ist amazing wer würde sich
nicht darüber freuen wenn man Honig mag
das ist das ist die Voraussetzung dass
man diesen honigkalender mag wenn ich
jetzt wirklich was kritisieren sollte
dann dass ich vielleicht so diese ein
oder andere Honig Kerze oder so gerne
drin gehabt hätte ich habe gesehen dass
die auch andere Produkte mieten ich habe
mir jetzt die nicht genau angeschaut
aber es ist ein Honig Adventskalender
deswegen ist es schon okay dass da nur
Honig drin ist ich glaube aber sie
könnten sogar in Zukunft dann Honig
related Adventskalender machen mit
Kerzen und sonst was man alles was Honig
machen kann zehn von zehn dieser
Adventskalender ist mega cool ich packe
euch den in die Infobox rein also gregas
im Karat das habt ihr richtig toll
gemacht mir fällt auch nichts weiteres
ein also sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder gönnt euch diesen Adventskalender
wenn ihr jemanden kennt der Honig liebt
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüssi